et avec nous pierre hurmic maire europe
ecologie les verts de bordeaux philippe
gonzalez maire de lubersac en corrèze
enfin karim khelfaoui médecins
généralistes bonsoir messieurs bonsoir à
tous les trois et merci d'être en direct
sur rt france le stade de france qui
s'est donc transformée aujourd'hui en
vaccinodromes géant
c'est la nouvelle arme du gouvernement
pour accélérer la campagne de
vaccination 46 vaccinodromes devrait
voir le jour dans le pays au mois
d'avril regarder cette carte pour vous
donner une idée à bordeaux d'ailleurs un
pierre hurmic et vous allez en avoir un
c'est net
avoir la chance d'en avoir en sait pas
encore si c'est vraiment une chance on
va essayer de décrypter ça ensemble ce
sont en tout cas sont présentés ainsi un
par le gouvernement comme une preuve
d'une accélération de la campagne pour
autant est-ce vraiment le cas selon vous
monsieur le maire on dirait surtout
l'usagé les points surtout il faut
éviter d'avoir des patrons péremptoire
comme chaque été c'est qu'on était celle
du ministre on a vu dans votre reportage
n'a pas de religion en la matière je
pense qu'il faut privilégier c'est le
pragmatisme oussama ou si ça marche ou
ça marche pas et ça marche pas si les
doses de vaccin sont au rendez vous on
met en place des lieux de vaccination
massive ont confortés qu'ils soient à la
hauteur de l'approvisionnement en
vaccins même si une deuxième condition
que nous nous avons posé sur la table
dès le début c'est qu'il ne faut pas que
ça se fasse au détriment des centres de
proximité
il faut vacciner tous azimuts et tous
azimuts ça veut dire ne pas privilégier
une solution technique au détriment
d'une autre
il faut des maximum parce que il faut
maintenant faire du massif qu'on a prévu
jusqu'à présent
mais il faut aussi faire du sur mesure
c'est à dire conserver des centres de
profit de proximité en ville comme dans
les comms dans les zones rurales ne font
pas vacciner tout le monde dans
l'élection de rendre ce n'est pas
forcément adapté à toutes les
populations et à tous les territoires
on va y revenir justement sur cette
notion de proximité parce qu'il ya
quelques critiques qui se concentrent
justement sur ce thème
on va aller voir de plus près comment ça
s'est passé aujourd'hui au stade de
france première matinée le plus grand au
centre de vaccination désormais dans le
pays nos équipes étaient sur place pour
recueillir le sentiment de ces
franciliens au moment de l'injection
regarder à l'inter s'est bien passée et
reçoit bien les gens ils s'occupent bien
mais bon les vaccins n'étaient pas là il
fallait qu'on attende
alors quand ça arrive et ça on attendait
vraiment un bon moment et puis 20
minutes une demi heure et puis après les
vaccins il est arrivé bah c'est mal
organisé tout le monde tourne en rond
les blouses blanches tout ça tout le
monde tourne en rond mais c'est très mal
organisé
pascal entrées on devrait nous donner un
numéro est passé par numéro mais là les
derniers passés les premiers nous
l'attend l'organisation s'est un peu à
peu le fouillis mais sinon ça va on
attend que tu peux
après on est enregistrée sur des
ordinateurs
voilà avec la capitale et tout ça pour
la sécu et ensuite on attend et un
médecin ou une infirmière qui avouent
chercher pour vous faire vacciner
or manifestement c'était pas toujours la
fête notamment au niveau de
l'organisation ce matin premier jour on
le rappelle quand même docteur vous vous
avez un petit peu de recours recul sur
le bec cynodrome à marseille notamment
au vélodrome
comment ça se passe on s'organise plutôt
bien ça permet de vacciner plus vite
alors ça permet d'avoir une organisation
effectivement de masse mais c'est
intéressant pour certains vaccins
notamment je pense au freezer qui a des
conditions de nécessité de rester dans
une chaîne du froid qui font qu'une
campagne décentralisée de vaccination
est un peu difficile avec ce vaccin mais
quelque part en fait depuis le début on
fait dans des centres de vaccination
pour ce vaccin
pour les autres c'est un peu moins un
peu moins forcément intéressant lé
astrazeneca le johnson and johnson qui
ne nécessite pas une chaîne du froid
particulière pourrait très bien faire
l'objet d'une campagne décentralisée est
en réalité à mon sens on est en train de
la de rentrer dans une nouvelle étape
d'une campagne de communication qui a
commencé maintenant il ya un mois et
demi où il a s'agit de dire qu'on avait
accéléré puisque ont passé d'une
vaccination chez les médecins à une
vaccination d'abord chez les pharmaciens
puis ensuite on nous a dit que les
vétérinaires etc vont pouvoir vacciner
maintenant on n'ouvre ses vaccinodromes
en réalité vous avez très bien poser le
problème le problème ce n'est pas la
manière dont on va aller structures
qu'on va faire pour faire cette campagne
de vaccination il faut qu'il y en ait de
tous types
mais c'est surtout est ce que on aura
assez de doses et c'est bien là que ça
pêche aujourd'hui on n'a absolument pas
plus de doses ou en tout cas ça arrive
un peu au fur et à mesure de ce que
veulent bien donner les laboratoires
pharmaceutiques et ça c'est un vrai
problème politique
c'est un vrai projet politique en france
et c'est un vrai problème politique dans
le monde entier parce qu'en réalité si
on fait une campagne de vaccination qui
n'est pas globale on risque de se
retrouver demain avec des variants qui
vont être sélectionnés parce que dans
certains pays on n'aura pas vacciner
aussi vite que en europe et que on va se
retrouver avec du coup des baryons qui
vont résister au vaccin il va falloir
vacciner tout le monde donc aujourd'hui
on a ce problème là et il est urgent
pour répondre à cette urgence à ce
problème là de lever les brevets sur les
vaccins c'est une possibilité que le
gouvernement a avec les licences
d'office pour lancer une campagne de
production de ces vaccins de masse et
qu'on ne soit pas obligé d'attendre que
des laboratoires privés
veuillez bien nous fournir sauf que pour
l'instant les laboratoires ne sont pas
vraiment d'accord en tout cas c'est une
grosse machine qui concentrent beaucoup
de moyens au détriment de des centres de
vaccination on le rappelle 1700 dans
dans le pays et je propose avant de
poursuivre ce débat de regarder
d'écouter ce tweet du député de la
france est soumise eric coquerel
l'ouverture du vaccinodromes du stade de
france peut être un soulagement
à condition que ça ne soit pas au
détriment des centres de proximité et
même qu on les renforce
chacun comprendra que c'est parfois
compliqué pour les personnes âgées d'à
jusqu'au stade qui est parfois loin de
ça fait écho à ce que nous disait un
pierre hurmic tout à l'heure et ça fait
écho aussi à beaucoup de critiques de la
part des pharmaciens et des maires
ruraux qu'on a entendu appeler le
gouvernement trouvait justement des
solutions de proximité est ce qu on a
fermé des centres de vaccination au
profit de vaccinodromes philippe
gonzalez vous qui être maire de lubersac
en corrèze oui effectivement il ya eu
une tentative disons de fermeture notre
de notre autres centres de vaccination
qui avait été mis en place depuis pas
mal de temps et qui assure et quand même
à notre échelle bien sûr une vaccination
adapté puisque bien sûr des grands les
grands centres sont utiles dans les
grandes concentrations de populations
dans les villes d'ailleurs on peut
constater qu'ils sont essentiellement
axées sur cette population là alors que
nous vous avez montré une carte qui
parle beaucoup
tout à l'heure c'est que ont remarqué
qu'un énorme trou vide au niveau du
centre de la france là justement où nous
nous trouvons et donc depuis le début
nous sommes mis au service de notre
population pour mettre en place tout ce
qu'il faut pour que la vaccination soit
faite et
et malheureusement le 1er avril c'était
pas un poisson nous annoncer que enfermé
le centre heureusement après après pas
mal de deux manifestations par les
médias par l'intermédiaire des médias
par notre facebook et l'intérêt sur
notre population à différents niveaux on
à la préfecture a réagi de façon
positive et nous annoncer que notre
centre ne serait pas fermé parce qu il
est bien évident que pour nous dans nos
zones rurales nous ne pouvons pas nous
occuper d'une population éparpillés sur
une surface assez grande
et puis les a menés d'une manière ou
d'une autre sur un centre qui serait à
une cinquantaine de kilomètres avec des
personnes qui sont relativement âgés
avec des comorbidités et avec des
problèmes associés alors que nono
médecin sur place et nos personnels
soignants sont tout à fait en mesure
d'abord de connaître les gens qui sont
amenés à vacciner et nous avons
suffisamment de mes deux bénévoles dans
nos villages pour les convoquer
nominalement et les fait revenir sans
quille et d'attentes sans qu'il y ait de
problème particulier avec aucun risque
pris
donc je crois que leur ne va pas sans
l'autre que l'on fasse des grands
centres de vaccination bien entendu si
logique si on veut être efficace sur une
population énorme puisque on vise l
intégralité de la population française
quand même mais surtout ne pas oublier
que dans nos zones à nous tout ce que
nous pouvons mettre en place sera utile
pour le recherche d'une solution
nationale et que tous les meilleurs mais
moi oui oui il ya beaucoup de critiques
de la part des des médecins aussi à on
entendait karim khelfaoui aussi qui
restait quand même
voilà mon modéré mais il y en a d'autres
qui sont vraiment en colère écouter jean
paul hamon le président d'honneur de la
fédération de la fédération des médecins
de france dans l'aisne mes copains
médecins généralistes me disent qu'ils
sont obligés d'annuler le rendez-vous de
vaccin car les flacons d'astra son parti
dans les centres de vaccination et qu'il
faut faire des bons de transport en
ambulance pour que leurs patients y
aille on vit une époque formidable
c'est vrai pierre hurmic beaucoup
d'aberrations dans cette campagne
parfois des des incohérences qu'on a du
mal à expliquer est-ce qu'on applique le
bon mari maillage territorial et la
bonne stratégie tout de même pour
vacciner massivement la population parce
qu'il fait une politique équilibrée je
suis assez sensible à ce que dit mon
collègue philippe gonzalez
il a raison je veux pas perdre de vue
les années rural je crois sans faire de
mapa 38% de la population vit dans des
communes de moins de 3500 habitants donc
naturellement il faut faire du sur
mesure du se mesure dans les zones
rurales
mais l'allemande dans les villes dans
les villes tout le monde ne peut pas
aller dans ces méga centres de
vaccination nous nous avons actuellement
cinq centres de proximité un bandeau
j'espère que nous allons les conserver
mais je souhaiterais même qu'elle est
davantage
et puis aussi un challenge qui concerne
autant les zones urbaines que les zones
rurales
c'est ce qu'on appelle la stratégie
duale et vert ya des gens qui peuvent
pas se déplacer
il fallait les voir nous ici au niveau
de la métropole bordelaise
on a pu négocier le sens de transfusion
sanguine qui nous prêtent leur leur mega
bus qui sert habituellement aux dons du
sang aux transfusions pour précisément
aller vers les populations qui ne
peuvent pas se déplacer et ouvert qui on
ira pour les vacciner les vaccine des
vaccinés sur place dont il n'y a pas une
solution
il ya plusieurs solutions il faut faire
de la dentelle que ça je disais il n'ya
pas de religion il n'ya pas de religion
soyons pragmatiques faisant dentelle
mais surtout nous n'avons pas
l'impression qu'on vaccine au mieux dans
les centres urbains
que dans les zones rurales je pense
qu'il faut là aussi un souci d'équilibré
surtout équité envers tous les
territoires
il ya aussi un problème de confiance
envers certains vaccins notamment celui
d' d'astrazeneca on rappelle que la
france a trois avec sa disposition pour
vacciner pour l'instant au stade de
france par exemple aujourd'hui est bien
et voulait tous du finder on s'est
aperçu à cette occasion d'ailleurs que
les doses de modern a été boudée comme
celle d'astrazeneca comment vous vous
l'expliquer karim khelfaoui je pense que
ça s'explique principalement par la
communication qui a eu autour de ces
vaccins celle de faiseurs on en a
beaucoup entendu parler et plutôt en
bien dans les différents médias
astrazeneca a eu des déboires puisqu'il
a été un moment suspendues et puis elle
réintroduit donc forcément ça n'aide pas
la confiance quand on sait que dès le
départ avancé vaccin arrive il y avait
une forte défiance par rapport au vaccin
et une forte crainte vu la vitesse à
laquelle ils avaient été développées et
qu'ils se basent tous sur un contre ces
trois là sur des technologies
relativement nouvelle ensuite le modern
abba lui il a fait à mon avis l'objet
d'un déficit de publicité dans les
médias et par le gouvernement donc tous
nous l'a un peu oublié parce qu'en fait
c'est un vaccin qui a été moins commandé
que les autres donc il ya moins de doses
donc on en a moins parlé mais en fait il
est à peu près comme le freezer à ceci
près qu'il est plus facile à conserver
qui a pas besoin d'une telle chaîne du
froid par rapport aux files heures il
est un petit peu moins contraignant mais
voilà après du coup on se retrouve dans
une situation où on se retrouve avec des
grands centres qui du coup que me
faisais mon confrère jean collin
on se retrouve à déshabiller pierre pour
habiller paul et les vaccins qu'on
pourrait faire de manière
beaucoup plus décentralisée avec l'aide
des différents professionnels de santé
parce qu'en réalité c'est par les
vaccinateurs qui n'ont que ça en a c'est
les vaccins tout simplement
donc aujourd'hui on est dans une
campagne de com où on va se retrouver à
mettre tous dans des vaccinaux droit au
détriment effectivement de certains
territoires qui vont avoir plus de mal à
trouver des d'autres au détriment de
médecins qui vont avoir plus de mal à
avoir des doses et par rapport à l'astra
et n'est qu'à par exemple il ya eu une
mauvaise publicité des gens qui le boude
complètement parce que ils ont pas ils
connaissent pas le médecin qui les
entretiens avant la vaccination ils
n'ont pas forcément confiance alors que
si ça se passait avec leur médecin
habituel leur médecin de famille peut
être que la discussion engagée
permettrait de les convaincre de faire
ce vaccin que c'est un jean pierre
gonzalez
évidemment on touche au coeur du
problème le manque de doses chez vous
les pharmaciens et les généralistes
tirent également la sonnette d'alarmé
ils ont peu de doses à leur disposition
pour vacciner leurs patients
oui effectivement on a un peu de 2 bien
faire tout est bon à prendre dans nos
dans notre situation donc je crois que
il faut que la population comprenne que
tous les vaccins sont utiles et que
faire de la sélection sera pas le
système idéal
il faudra absolument que on se persuade
que le que le risque encouru est
nettement plus faible que le bénéfice ce
qui sera au bout du compte pour nous
c'est capital que les gens comprennent
qu'il faut se faire vacciner aujourd'hui
et que nous mettons tout en oeuvre nous
et en nos campagnes la plus reculée pour
que ça se fasse le plus vite possible
mais effectivement le sud et centrale
c'est le nombre de doses c'est évident
et la méthode pour lui pardonnez moi oui
puis à l'aube thermique justement sur
cette question dès des vaccins de la
confiance un les doses ça de toute façon
voilà on
on n'a pas bien le choix on les attendra
mais vous concernant justement ce choix
de weixin vous allez avoir le choix vous
justement où vaccinodromes de bordeaux
comment ça va se passer comment vous
allez gérer cette question vous allez
essayer de faire de la pédagogie
l avantage simuler des vaccinodromes
c'est pour ça que c'était choisissez que
on te faire du fric du pikes peak en
isère c'est à dire de la rn messager qui
ne peut se conserver que dans des
conditions de froid exceptionnelle qu'on
peut pas faire en médecine de ville
c'est un peu plus compliqué or
actuellement tout le monde réclame du
faillitaire et c'était comme ça a été
dit là se raser les cas est un peu est
un peu bu des donc les grands centres
offre des facilités de conservation que
n'offre pas forcément tous les des
petits centres de proximité mais je
prends comme un con c'est intentionnel
et on verra les populations il faut il
faut les rassurer bien entendu enfin en
tant que bien moi je vais tout faire
pour les inciter ce que je fais déjà
depuis quelques temps à aller se faire
vacciner le plus rapidement possible en
vue d'aider quel que soit le type de
vaccin actuellement l'urgence des gens
c'est de se faire vacciner
j'ajoute qu'on attend avec impatience
ici comme ailleurs l'arrivée du vaccin
johnson and johnson qui présente le
mérite inouïe d'avoir une seule une
seule vaccination dont quand je vous
parlais tout à l'heure d'aller vers les
gens aller vers les gens en iran le jour
on sera en mesure de leur garantir
qu'une seule vaccination suffit et pour
ça il nous faut rapidement je crois que
c'est annoncé pour un peu près mi-avril
le vaccin jones un geste simple qui va
tous nous mettre d'accord par sa
facilité de sa facilité de doses uniques
alors il ya d'autres annonces
en tout cas du gouvernement qui peuvent
être sujettes à caution on va voir des
vaccins anti qu'ovide fabriqués en
france et les dates de lancement
regarder cette carte des vaccins donc
produit en france
la france qui va en quelque sorte servir
de sous traitants là aussi beaucoup de
communication une manière pour le
gouvernement de de marquer son
territoire mais tout de même il faut
comprendre que les entreprises donc un
rôle de sous-traitant et elles ne
pourront pas faire de miracle si on ne
leur fournit pas assez de ces principes
actifs pour que le vaccin soit efficace
n'est ce pas karim khelfaoui il faut se
méfier mais alors ça ne veut pas dire
qu'on va être tout d'un coup enseveli de
vaccins en france
non pas du tout parce qu'il aurait été
comme vous l'avez dit c'est encore une
nouvelle campagne de communication
parce que par exemple sur le faisaient
en biotech
il ne s'agit pas de produire du vaccin
en france mais de faire de la sous
traitance sur lens l'acconage tout
simplement
donc on n'est pas du tout dans quelque
chose on va produire quelque chose
le vaccin en france c'est pas ça et puis
surtout on a toujours la même le même
problème qui est qu'il ya d'autres
vaccins qui sont disponibles et vous
disiez tout à l'heure on est on va être
obligés d'attendre des doses mais non
c'est pas vrai la campagne a commencé en
décembre
en décembre il était possible de prendre
une décision politique qui consistait à
dire nous avons besoin des vaccins nous
allons lever les prouver il c'est
possible dans la loi c'est une décision
politique à prendre donc nous allons
mettre en marche l'industrie
pharmaceutique française la
réquisitionner pour fabriquer toutes les
doses dont nous avons besoin ça on
estime qu'il faut quatre mois pour
mettre la machine en branle et créer
tout ce qu'il fallait comme celle de
production si ça allait défier endéans
aujourd'hui effectivement serait en
train de produire tous les vaccins
donnés
non ça n'a pas été fait et ce n'est
toujours pas fait et on va vous sortir
l'argument ça ne se fait pas du jour au
lendemain ben oui ben n'étant comprend
pas la décision politique il ya rien qui
se fera ça c'est évident et ensuite à
côté de ça il ya d'autres vaccins qui
sont disponibles mais qui sont boudés
par les autorités et notamment les
autorités françaises je pense aux
vaccins russe qui a démontré une
efficacité dans des études avec revue
par les pairs notamment dans the lands
est donc il ya plus de discussions sur
l'efficacité de ce vaccin
et pourtant il ya toujours aucune
commande on nous dit que c'est un
problème administratif qui bloque mais
enfin de quoi de qui on se moque
si on a besoin de vaccin aujourd'hui on
va voir les russes ont dit ben on veut
votants d'axa et puis on y va quoi et on
fait passer à l'année scène tous les
tests dont on a besoin pour s'assurer de
la sécurité du produit
et puis on fait pareil pour le vaccin
chinois et on fait pareil pour tous les
vaccins qui sont en train d'être
développé aujourd'hui on est bloqué sur
quelques entreprises occidentales parce
qu'il s'agit bien de géopolitique
c'est à dire qu'on a favorisé les
entreprises occidentales qui fabrique
c'est là que ça et on n'a commandé que
chez eux et aujourd'hui on se retrouve
bloquée parce qu'il ya une situation de
pénurie qui était facilement on pouvait
l'anticiper
on n'a pas par idéologie on n'a pas
commandé ailleurs on n'a pas commandé
chez d'autres d'autres pays et on n'a
pas mis en place les moyens juridiques
et industriels pour faire en sorte que
l'on produise en france tout ce dont on
avait besoin donc le nombre de doses qui
nous manque aujourd'hui c'est un
problème politique c'est de la
responsabilité du gouvernement et de
personne d'autre
pierre hurmic le mot de la fin pour vous
alors concernant spoutnik v1 c'est vrai
que l'agencé européenne du médicament ne
se prononcera pas avant la fin juin
c'est vrai qu'il ya une lenteur qu'on ne
peut que remarquer vous êtes d'accord
avec cette analyse et ce sera le mot de
la fin pour vous de votre collègue karim
khelfaoui ce soir je suis pas médecin
mais je crois qu'effectivement il ya un
problème d'approvisionnement
et quand on est placé face à une pénurie
puisque actuellement c'est quand même
une pénurie je crois que toutes les
solutions
il ne faut en bout d aucune pour
comparis paunic vais une fois qu'il aura
subi les contrôles européens nécessaire
je pense qu'il faut pas s'aveugler sur
une source de médecins plutôt qu'une
autre je crois que actuellement il faut
se donner les moyens de diversifier au
maximum une source d'approvisionnement
pour arriver ste maxime cette
vaccination massive qui est impatiemment
attendue
merci à tous les trois messieurs pierre
hurmic pierre philippe part dans thales
et karim khelfaoui d'avoir été avec nous
en direct sur rt france